Elisa Rojas vous êtes avocate du droit
du travail et militante pour le droit
des handicapés l'Inde va pas sans
l'autre votre métier est essentiellement
au service de cette cause mon métier en
fait moi je distingue un peu les deux
l'essentiel de mon activité
professionnelle c'est vrai c'est du
droit du travail au côté des salariés
après j'ai une formation généraliste
donc il m'est arrivé de traiter d'autres
types de dossiers mais je fais toujours
du droit des personnes et par contre le
droit du handicap m'intéresse à
plusieurs titres parce que je suis une
personne concernée d'abord parce que le
droit voilà c'est ma profession et que
sur le plan militant il me semble qu'il
y a beaucoup de choses à faire donc
c'est vrai que le droit de du handicap
c'est plutôt l'aspect militant de mon
activité d'accord un mot sur le port du
masque de toute évidence nous ne sommes
pas égaux face à la maladie vous êtes
plus vulnérable face au covid d'où le
port de ce masque comment exercez-vous
d'ailleurs votre métier en cette période
de pandémie
très difficilement
quand je vais plaider il y a non
seulement le stress qui est logique et
qui est normal donc cette activité c'est
toute une organisation qui est forcément
plus complexe que la moyenne mais
désormais je prends un risque sanitaire
celui de tomber malade puisque toutes
les mesures ont été levées on est dans
une situation assez étrange où tout le
monde veut oublier qu'il y a une
pandémie et un virus qui circule donc en
fait quand on est une personne
handicapée qu'on travaille les
équilibres sont très fragiles alors je
vous remercie d'avoir pris la peine
d'être venu sur ce plateau aujourd'hui
l'essentiel de votre activité c'est donc
de prêter votre voix au sans voix
est-ce que je dirais ça comme ça je ne
sais pas je dirais ça peut-être encore
plus simplement
il se trouve que j'ai développé une
aptitude à me défendre moi-même que j'ai
eu envie de mettre au service des autres
et de la même façon tout ce que j'ai
appris dans le cadre de mon métier j'ai
envie de le mettre au service de mon
militantisme c'est un peu comme ça que
les choses se sont construites alors
justement votre concurrensara carteudo
qui est à la fois malentendante et
malvoyante et qui œuvre pour faire
entendre la voix des handicapés dans les
tribunaux estiment que lorsqu'on veut
défendre les autres c'est souvent que
l'on veut se défendre soi-même pour
partager ce constat je sais pas si je le
formulerai de cette façon là mais là où
je peux comprendre cette phrase c'est
que en effet je suis persuadée que c'est
le fait d'avoir été obligé de me
défendre constamment tout le long de mon
parcours notamment scolaire qui m'a
donné envie de défendre ceux on avait
besoin puisque je me suis trouvée et pas
si mauvaise dans la défense de mes
propres intérêts ça m'a obligé à
développer certaines certains sans doute
très de caractère etc et que je me suis
dit autant en faire un métier il existe
peut-être que je peux être utile à
d'autres personnes le handicap et le
premier motif de discrimination en
France selon le Défenseur des droits
diriez-vous donc que le handicap et la
dernière minorité après les Noirs les
homosexuels les trans qui n'a pas encore
commencé sa vraie lutte
alors déjà c'est la minorité en termes
de chiffres la plus importante comme
vous l'avez dit c'est la première cause
de ces in auprès du Défenseur des droits
je pourrais pas dire de façon aussi
catégorique que la lutte n'a pas
commencé parce qu'en vérité elle l'a
commencé il y a eu des choses qui se
sont faites dans les années 70 qui sont
peu connus mais qui ont existé justement
dans les mouvances militantes de
l'époque mais ça son titre le féminisme
etc il y avait des militants handicapés
politisés malheureusement leur combat ne
s'est pas inscrit dans la durée et on
peut passer à la trappe on le redécouvre
aujourd'hui et c'est tant mieux par
ailleurs sur le plan mondial il y a des
pays où cette lutte là est beaucoup plus
enracinée beaucoup plus connu du grand
public c'est en France en fait où je
pense qu'on a oui en effet cette
particularité d'avoir oublié une partie
de notre histoire et d'avoir la
sensation aujourd'hui de tout devoir
reprendre depuis le début
vous interrogez à raison le principe de
la normalité avez-vous réussi du moins
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions à
déconstruire les stéréotypes liées au
handicap et à les perceptions que l'on
peut en avoir dit autrement est-ce que
les justiciables ont des réticences à
venir faire appel à vous ou au contraire
c'est un atout alors en fait je pense
pas que les gens voient les choses sous
cet angle là je pense que une personne
qui va avoir un avocat c'est quelqu'un
qui a un problème qui va avoir un
professionnel et qui est content quand
il trouve un professionnel qui peut le
soutenir qui peut l'aider qui peut le
renseigner et il accompagne par exemple
dans une procédure ce que je fais donc
je pense que c'est surtout ça que les
les clients voient en moi un atout
d'être dans une communauté de situation
si j'ose dire c'est à dire
ça peut ça peut l'être en effet moi je
trouve ça très bien que il y ait moins
de distance entre les professionnels et
ceux qui ne sont pas professionnels je
trouve ça toujours une bonne chose que
l'on puisse trouver quand on en a besoin
des professionnels qui soient plus
proches voilà après il y a quand même
une distance parce que ça reste une
relation professionnelle mais bien sûr
que je me sens moins éloigné de certains
parcours voir qu'à très proche pour ceux
qui pourraient avoir un parcours
vraiment très similaire ou bien sûr et
c'est et c'est tant mieux si c'est le
cas mais après je relativise toujours ce
qui est essentialisant et je voudrais
pas laisser croire que je sais pas que
ça importe vraiment quelque chose ça
c'est très particulier il y a une
relation de ce confiance qui se crée ou
pas entre un avocat et son client
parfois ça fonctionne pas parfois ça
fonctionne très très bien et dans ces
cas-là c'est même génial mais vraiment
quelque chose de très enrichissant mais
mais oui je comprends ce que vous voulez
dire au sens où moi je trouve que c'est
important pour tout le monde de pouvoir
que ce soit un avocat ou un médecin
pouvoir avoir le choix d'aller vers un
professionnel qui vous ressemble
davantage vous luttez ardemment contre
la présomption d'un capacité que la
société renvoie aux personnes en
situation de handicap le problème c'est
que on les identifié que par rapport à
cet aspect or la situation est beaucoup
plus complexe que ça et on ne peut pas
être
identifié que par rapport à cet élément
qui veut pas dire non plus qui font
tomber dans le travers inverse et faire
de nous des gens qui voilà ne sont
absolument pas limités il y a des
limites qui existent du fait du handicap
mais pour autant elle justifie pas que
l'on soit entravé dans notre vie tous
ces aspects
l'avocat d'affaires est professeur de
droit Stéphane baller dit toute personne
handicapée qui souhaite embrasser ce
métier n'a pas d'autre choix que d'être
extraordinaire à la fois dans sa manière
d'exercer et de se déplacer
êtes-vous une surface et les Arras non
pas du tout et je ne suis pas d'accord
avec cette façon de voir les choses et
de présenter les choses moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de faire du bon
travail je le fais avec conscience avec
rigueur et avec passion aussi parce que
c'est très intéressant mais je ne suis
pas une surface je ne suis pas une
héroïne je suis humaine je suis faible
je suis aussi complexe que n'importe qui
d'autre que exercice métier ça tient
parfois pour vous du parcours du
combattant même les études ont dû être
compliqué oui c'est un parcours du
combattant mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est
d'essayer de comprendre quel est le
système qui transforme ce parcours en
parcours du combattant en fait et
surtout dans le cadre professionnel je
pense qu'il est dangereux que on
soumette les personnes handicapées à une
exigence supplémentaire le fait d'être
compétent doit suffire à nous prendre au
sérieux en tant que professionnel on n'a
pas à répondre à cette exigence d'être
surhumain ça me paraît absolument
injuste donc si les gens cherchent une
héroïne faut pas frapper à ma porte faut
aller voir ceux qui aiment jouer au
héros ou je sais pas c'est pas mon cas
parce que est-ce que le milieu de
l'avocatures est un milieu
inclusif il était pas réputé comme tel
parce que ça a changé alors est-ce que
ça a changé ce serait difficile à dire
j'ai pas beaucoup de chiffres et
d'indicateurs pour pouvoir l'affirmer
moi quand j'ai commencé je peux pas
considérer que c'était un milieu
inclusif je pense honnêtement qu'il est
à l'image de plein d'autres oui de la
société de plein d'autres secteurs
professionnels ce qui est un peu gênant
c'est que nous en tant qu'avocat on est
supposé connaître les textes notamment
en matière de discrimination donc
peut-être faudrait-il qu'on s'interroge
un tout petit peu en termes
d'exemplarité mais on n'est pas
différent les difficultés rencontrées ne
sont pas différentes d'ailleurs
justement vous pointez du doigt une
société qui n'est pas conçue pour tous
la mise aux normes entre Triple
guillemets des bâtiments publics
commerce de proximité cabinet médico
gare hôtel transport extra traîne il y a
eu un report de la loi en 2005 ou en
sommes-nous aujourd'hui
on va voir ce qui va se passer puisque
on doit arriver bientôt à la fin des
reports de délais sans doute c'est déjà
incroyable qui ait eu un report
d'ailleurs ce report il a eu lieu
justement pour éviter la création d'un
contentieux qui à partir de 2015 aurait
pu se développer ça devenait
l'accessibilité une obligation de
résultats donc tout équipement qui
n'avait pas répondu à ce résultat était
susceptible de d'être mis en cause par
une personne handicapée qui aurait pu
multiplier les actions pour éviter ça
comme il y avait beaucoup de bâtiments
publics de concernés et bien on a
modifié le volet accessibilité de la loi
de 2005 on a reporté les délais une fois
de plus et on a créé un dispositif
totalement une usine à gaz en fait que
sont les agendas d'accessibilité
maintenant on arrive certainement un
moment donné bientôt au bout de ses
agendas qu'est-ce qui va se passer ça
c'est une bonne question notamment si on
plonge judiciaire est-ce qu'on va enfin
pouvoir voir émerger un contentieux qui
peut-être serait souhaitable pour que
les choses avancent vous-même vous avez
été pénalisés dans l'exercice de vos
fonctions qui s'apparente parfois il
faut le dire à une épreuve de Pékin
Express vous êtes retrouvé
dans la cuisine du conseil des
prud'hommes de Villeneuve-Saint-Georges
oui enfin en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que ce jour-là j'arrive pour
l'audience et puis je m'aperçois que la
salle est à l'étagée qu'il n'y a pas
d'ascenseur et puis ce jour là j'ai pas
eu envie de faire comme si rien n'était
et de me faire porter pour accéder à la
salle d'audience j'ai signalé qu'il y
avait une difficulté et l'alternative
proposée c'était de plaider dans la
cuisine donc c'est ce que j'ai fait je
pense pas qu'il y a beaucoup de
confrères qui est plaidé un jour dans la
cuisine d'un contenu des prud'hommes
c'était très étrange mais au-delà de mon
cas personnel que je trouve pas très
intéressant c'est vraiment
l'accessibilité profiter de la justice
dans un pays comme la France qui pose
problème surtout que les personnes
handicapées ont leur droit bafoué
quotidiennement si le jour où ils ont
envie d'agir ils se retrouvent une fois
de plus devant des bâtiments qui ne sont
pas accessibles et une justice qui n'est
pas accessible c'est absolument
scandaleux alors il n'y a pas que la
question de l'accessibilité physique
certains plaignant doivent faire appel à
des ambulanciers privés à leurs frais
pour assister aux audiences d'autres ont
recours à des interprètes en langage des
signes toujours à leurs frais une femme
malentendante a dû mimer le viol qu'elle
avait subi faute de pouvoir le raconter
avec des mots les anecdotes ne manquent
pas d'un dispositif judiciaire pas du
tout adapté aux personnes en situation
de handicap oui mais l'accessibilité au
sens où je l'entends moi ça comprend
évidemment pas que les l'accessibilité
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
c'est vraiment pour l'ensemble des
handicaps et donc c'est entièrement
accessible que doit être vous avez
j'imagine entendu parler de cette
histoire 16 militants handicapés ont été
condamnés en première instance ça
dépanne avec sursis à des amandes pour
avoir bloqué la gare SNCF et l'aéroport
de Toulouse en 2018 or c'est dangereux
activiste ne réclamait qu'une seule
chose le droit de vivre comme tout le
monde que vous inspire à la fois ses
actions de désobéissance civile et se
jugement
je le trouve triste parce que je pense
que
criminaliser toutes les actions
militantes telles qu'elles soient ben
c'est pour silencier les gens les
effrayer donc je trouve ça assez triste
mais surtout ce qui est incroyable dans
cette histoire c'est qu'en première
instance il y avait des problèmes
d'accessibilité pour la tenue de cette
audience là donc la justice veut
criminaliser des militants handicapés
mais n'a pas les moyens de les juger
dans des conditions dignes et de leur
offrir un procès équitable ce qui montre
que la raison pour laquelle ils ont agi
même illégalement était parfaitement et
c'est à ça je la connais d'autant mieux
que j'ai été cité par l'association
comme témoin pour les soutenir en appel
et que voilà enfin je j'ai considéré
qu'il était totalement naturel
d'apporter mon soutien à des militants
qui ont pris des risques pour nous tous
toutes les personnes handicapées dans la
même situation et quand on fait du droit
on sait une chose très importante il y a
ce qui est juste et yes qui est légal et
parfois ce qui est illégal peut être
juste donc il faut bien faire la
distinction et heureusement à travers
l'histoire il y a des gens qui ont su
faire la distinction et les pour que les
choses changent pour que les choses
bougent parfois il faut en passer par
des actions de ce type mettre le droit
c'est la mise en oeuvre d'une politique
se battre sur le plan judiciaire c'est
la meilleure façon de faire progresser
les lois et donc le politique je pense
que le droit est un outil de lutte c'est
l'un des outils c'est pas magique on
peut pas tout attendre et tout ne peut
pas résulter des procédures mais puisque
c'est un outil il faut l'utiliser
parfois ils permettent de faire avancer
les choses et il y a eu beaucoup
d'exemples à travers les combats sociaux
qui ont été menés qui montrent l'intérêt
également de de se servir du droit comme
dans l'outil vous vous étiez fait
connaître en 2015 après une tribune
incendiaire dans le monde contre le
Téléthon à qui vous reprochiez une
vision à la fois larmoyante
misérabiliste et charitable du handicap
les choses n'ont pas bougé
non j'ai j'ai pas la sensation qu'on
aille vers le progrès et c'est ça que je
trouve particulièrement inquiétant on
est même plutôt dans une phase de
régression en termes de droit pour les
personnes handicapées et bien il y a
quand même eu pas mal de réformes qui
sont pas des réformes qui vont dans le
sens de l'émancipation et de l'égalité
ne serait-ce que par exemple la loi Elan
la réduction du nombre de logements
accessibles dans le bâtiment neuf c'est
une régression
que nous avions reçu ici pour évoquer
son parcours échanger le regard sur le
handicap s'inscrit dans une démarche
résolument apolitique contrairement à
vous en quoi politiser le handicap et
pour vous une nécessité alors je crois
pas qu'il y ait en quelleque sujet qui
soit impolitique je ne crois pas on
l'existence de personnes à politique ou
des sujets à politique
tout est politique parce qu'à chaque
fois qu'on s'interroge on en arrive
toujours à une question de fond qui
fondamental et qui est dans quelle
société on souhaite vivre c'est à ça
qu'on renvoie chaque débat donc le
handicap la santé le covid tout ça ce
sont des choix et des questions
politiques moi je sais personnellement
dans quel type de société j'ai envie de
vivre et j'ai voilà je vais dans ce sens
et je défends tout ce qui peut permettre
de construire cette société là une
société d'égalité de justice de justice
sociale et de répartition des richesses
aussi que vous inspire l'affaire de
disparus de l'Yonne résolus après quatre
décennies grâce à l'entêtement d'une
avocate Corinne Hermann il voyait vous
comme d'autres le symptôme d'un
dysfonctionnement grave de l'état d'une
violence institutionnelle aussi vous
militez d'ailleurs contre contre la
fermeture des institutions spécialisées
et vous pointez du doigt les défaillants
des associations en quoi elles peinent à
défendre vos droits les associations et
les institutions ça se peut spécialisés
les associations
gestionnaires qu'on appelle quelque
chose qui sont les très grosses
associations qui gèrent des
établissements spécialisés et des
services pour les personnes handicapées
sont devenus le relais de l'Etat en fait
elle reçoivent énormément d'argent
public pour maintenir un système qui
porte atteinte au droit des personnes
handicapées ça c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est l'ONU et qui est un système
institutionnel donc qui consiste à
regrouper les personnes handicapées
entre elles à les couper du reste de la
société aller faire vivre dans des
bâtiments qui leur sont destinés ça
c'est une atteinte au droit des
personnes handicapées on sait parce que
au niveau international oui c'est une
ségrégation les textes internationaux le
disent il y a des études qui montrent
tous les impacts négatifs de
l'institutionnalisation sur les
personnes handicapées sa nuit au
développement des enfants ça favorise
tout type de maltraitance et d'abus
c'est absolument ahurissant que ce soit
à nous les militants de d'expliquer en
quoi il y a une difficulté sur cette
question donc
en cela elle est très symptomatique de
ces dysfonctionnements bien sûr parce
que si les crimes ont pu durer aussi
longtemps c'est que personne en réalité
ne se préoccupe de ce qui se passe dans
ces espaces là donc pour moi ça révèle
bien l'abandon qui est celui des
personnes handicapées en institution le
désintérêt de l'ensemble de la société
pour ce qui peut leur arriver dans ces
endroits donc je trouve oui que c'est
assez grave et d'ailleurs ça a donné
lieu à toute une réflexion qui
malheureusement n'a pas abouti sur les
maltraitances en institution permettre
aux personnes handicapées de faire leur
propre choix de vie de définir leur
propre besoin et prendre leur propre
décision serait un combat que vous
pourriez envisager de porter devant les
plus hautes juridictions de l'État
moi personnellement je sais je sais pas
si j'en aurai l'occasion mais est-ce que
il faudrait s'il y a matière et si il y
a des dossiers qui le permettent bien
sûr et même au-delà il y a des justes
juridictions internationale aussi donc
l'importance c'est d'aller le plus loin
possible pour tout ce qui peut faire
avancer les droits des personnes
handicapées et qui va dans le sens de
leur aimantation surtout vous auriez
envie de mener ce combat
moi personnellement je ne sais pas en
fait ce que j'ai surtout constaté au
tout début de ma carrière c'est que
avant d'être en capacité de d'élaborer
des stratégies judiciaires pour les
personnes handicapées il fallait
construire un discours politique sur
lequel sur lequel ces stratégies
pourraient s'appuyer et le problème
c'est que ce discours politique là ben
on le trouvait pas en fait donc il
fallait d'abord le développer le
construire et c'est vrai que j'ai fait
le choix plutôt que de développer ma
carrière professionnelle autour de
dossiers qui concerne les personnes
handicapées plutôt essayer de participer
à la construction de ce discours qui me
paraissait un préalable indispensable
pour être sûr d'aller dans la bonne
direction pour qu'un jour il y ait des
stratégies qui puissent se construire
mais qui du coup ne partent pas dans
tous les sens sache exactement dans
quelle direction aller parce que si vous
faites des actions pour demander plus de
place en institution on va pas le dans
son sens de l'émancipation alors que si
on a un discours où on sait ce que veut
dire l'émancipation ce que l'on
revendique exactement qu'est-ce qui
porte atteinte au droit des personnes
handicapées après en tant que
professionnel on est en mesure de
construire des des stratégies des
actions qui vont répondre à ces
impératifs là en attendant vous avez été
Élisa Rojas sinon la première du moins
l'une des rares femmes en fauteuil
roulant avoir fait la Une d'un magazine
féminin français cette couverture de
Marie-Claire en mars 2021 a-t-elle fait
bouger les lignes quand même
alors moi je pense qu'une couverture de
magazine féminin aussi belle sur la tête
ne suffit pas à modifier des structures
aupressives ou des représentations ce
qui ne veut pas dire que ce n'est pas
important moi je suis contente de savoir
qu'il y a des femmes handicapées qui se
sont vues pour la première fois à
travers moi sur la couverture d'un
magazine féminin mais je n'ai pas la
naïveté de croire que ça suffit à
changer la donne ce sera définitivement
le cas quand ce genre de couverture ne
sera même plus en événement alors est-ce
que l'absence de représentants
politiques en situation de handicap
pourrait faire bouger justement parce
que aujourd'hui il y en a pas en
Allemagne il y a eu Wolfgang shubble
plusieurs fois ministres financent
notamment et qui lui a promu les
personnes en situation de handicap elle
s'est faite donc cette promotion au plus
haut niveau de l'État tout le monde
porte un handicap rappelle-t-il la seule
différence c'est que nous percer en
situation de handicap nous en sommes au
moins conscient vous êtes d'accord avec
cela
non pas totalement parce que
dire tout le monde en handicap c'est un
peu comme dire je ne vois pas les
couleurs pour nier le racisme structurel
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait tout le monde
peut devenir handicapé ça c'est vrai ce
qui le sont pas peuvent le devenir
mais oui mais par contre à un moment T
on n'est pas tous traité socialement
comme des personnes handicapées il y a
des gens qui sont traités socialement
comme des personnes handicapées et
d'autres pas jusqu'à ce qu'elle devienne
handicapées donc je réduirai pas le
propos à dire on est tous handicapés ça
me paraît pas exactement la bonne
présentation des choses
davantage de représentants politiques en
situation d'handicap nous avons eu
Damien Abad qui est rentré au
gouvernement indépendamment de ce qui
lui est arrivé par la suite de son dont
il a été accusé mais ça a été
le seul il y a deux autres députés
aujourd'hui en situation de handicap qui
sont aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée c'est peu
c'est une représentation quand même
dérisoire au regard des quelques douze
millions de Français touchés par un
handicap non
plus de représentants ça c'est
l'évidence bien sûr que c'est important
on doit être présent partout et vous
vous auriez pas envie de vous lancer en
politique
franchement
j'ai l'impression déjà de faire de la
politique parce que je pense que on peut
faire de la politique de plein de façon
différente j'en fais à travers mon
métier j'en fais à travers mon
militantisme j'en fais là devant vous
pour moi ça s'appelle faire de la
politique pour autant faire de la
politique au sens où vous l'entendez de
façon classique on peut jamais dire
jamais parce que sinon on va m'en
ressortir la bobine le jour où je
prendrai une décision différente vous
avez été approchée
à militer oui c'est ce sont des des
démarches qui sont régulières mais
honnêtement j'ai pas spécialement envie
de politique là maintenant mais c'est
étrange parce que vous militez
activement pour que le pouvoir ne reste
pas toujours aux mains des mêmes et
pourtant vous ne vous décidez pas à en
politique mais moi je trouve pas ça
contradictoire parce qu'on peut pas tout
attendre de quelqu'un je ne suis pas
providentiel
vous militez quand même pour pour
prendre le pouvoir pour que le pouvoir
ne reste pas aux mains on peut être
militant et rester militant qu'il y ait
des gens qui après et envie de faire de
la politique je trouve ça logique je
peux comprendre cette démarche là mais
je vois pas pourquoi je serais obligée
il y a zéro incohérence pour moi dans le
fait de pas avoir envie d'en faire la
politique c'est un milieu extrêmement
violent j'exerce déjà un métier qui
comporte une part de violence être
militant c'est aussi naviguer dans un
milieu qui n'est pas spécialement tendre
donc je me préserve et je fais ce qui me
semble
dans les dans mes cordes au moment où je
peux le faire et en même temps elle
disait alors vous êtes une guerrière
le contexte fait que j'ai pas
franchement le choix c'est votre mère
qui vous a appris ça ça devient une
guerrière
c'est quelqu'un de très combatif ça
c'est sûr et certain que je lui dois mon
tempérament c'est quelqu'un que je n'ai
jamais vu accepter une situation injuste
ou se résigner qui m'a toujours
manifester son soutien sans me mettre la
pression sans décider à ma place mais
qui m'a toujours fait comprendre que
quel que soit mes choix elle serait là
pour me soutenir et notamment quand
j'étais plus petite et que j'étais
confronté à des difficultés sur le plan
scolaire elle me disait si tu veux
continuer si tu veux te battre moi je
vais me battre avec toi donc on s'est
battu ensemble voilà donc dans beaucoup
de circonstances il est clair que j'ai
beaucoup appris de la façon dont elle
prenait les choses
ça sera le mot de la fin diriez-vous que
on en aura fini avec l'inclusion quand
le mot inclusion sera supprimé
à ce stade je sais même pas exactement
ce que recouvre le mot inclusion mais
moi je préfère le mot égalité et non
discrimination parce que là pour moi ça
me parle je suis avocate ce sont des
termes juridiques clairs le mot
inclusion voilà c'est une façon de noyer
le poisson je même si je comprends
l'idée pour moi ce qui compte c'est
vraiment qu'on comprenne qu'il y a un
système qui freine et que c'est ce
système qu'il faut comprendre analyser
combattre pour le faire disparaître je
vous laisse le mot de la fin
merci
à vous